all right we have a 2018 Hyundai Santa
Fe we plug the OBD Port right there and
we want to go ahead and add a second key
so we're going to go ahead and turn the
car on first
we will go to Hyundai
and we can do automatic selection
read the VIN number
ignition is on
and click ok
we are in the USA
2018 Santa Fe Sport
it is a smart key
and this is the key that we will be
adding to the vehicle
and let's do a scan to the vehicle
and that's their original key
so we have a new key and the original
key
number of keys are two so let's go ahead
and let's read the PIN code
and
let's see
let's try that
all right so let's go check out which
key this is just double check all right
so what we're going to do is we put
their key inside and we are just gonna
go to
transponder clone and read the
transponder
and that tells us it's a 46 chip right
over there
so now we will go to our
OBD
m508 read the PIN code
and repent code by OBD
okay
all right turn the hazard light on
open and close
foreign
off
and the screen should be black so let's
open and close the door so it's black
and let's click ok
pin code is zero zero four eight nine
five
okay
now we want to go back and we want to
add a smart key
so add key
start
all right open and close the door
yeah all right so we're going to click
ok
and we will hit the back of this
I want to push to start and that is a
success do we want to add another key
and we do that's our second key right
there
let's
click yes
and as you see right now it doesn't do
anything to the car
and we will click ok
and we will hit the back of that
to
the start stop button and it says
succeed
and number of keys are now two
so let's click ok
perfect
and Escape
amazing now this case should now work
the car as you see it now works
so
that is all for the programming thank
you very much
for following us